hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doom eternal we're
on our way to rip the head off of a
priest so that should be pretty fun
pretty excited about that that's gonna
be great also I've got a bunch of weapon
points that I probably should use but am
I going to yes I'm gonna get fast to
reload on this 50 demons of the super
shotgun while using the meathook I need
this because this is gonna help me get a
lot of armor I want it I want that
really badly and I'm gonna use this
anyway just because it is whoa whoa okay
we're right into it okay you Oh No oh
there we go
I'm try I don't know why I'm trying to
do that whoo that was dumb oh yes yes
yes yes that was really dumb of me okay
you okay you owe me this doesn't seem
like a machine oh this seems like a mini
rocket launcher which is even better I
guess
ah no all right well that was sloppy but
you know whatever oh I wasn't
chainsawing anybody why was I not doing
that because I'm dumb oh that's what it
is
sure I guess I could have just unhooked
it I know I'll punch it I'll punch it
off it's fine oh that facility the one I
should have been looking at oh right
yeah the big glowing thing in front of
me the one that anybody could have
noticed but I did not for some reason
man they put it in a lot of work in
these environments these are just big
sprawling cool places like really
legitimately cool Oh huh is it time wait
no I need to barely
that's what I need to do okay you I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get this meathook
mastery up sucks for you it really sucks
oh you guys you poor fellow's okay wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait a
fight that's fun as is plain old fun
that is really fun right there I love
that this is gonna hurt
oh no it's fine oh okay oh this of
course oh there we go
man climbing things really clunky in
this game whoo this one she could it
don't leave me behind
don't leave me I am dumb take two okay
there we go
all right am I just getting to that is
that what I'm going for
I think I can make that if not I'll have
to oh my god I thought I wasn't gonna
make it nailed it though because I'm
great boop boop link Oh didn't see that
hello thank you yes please
all right let's get up here I love is
just the pulsating music it seems like
prep for a boss battle can't exactly do
anything else I guess I could get a heat
blast
yeah maybe I should do that because
microwave it's nice and all but also it
prevents me from like doing other things
whereas this probably is just like punk
I don't have any heat built up that's
why I let's do this this is an arena
Oh kill its tail
you got it Bubba you got it I'm ready
you love it
whoa didn't see you there
my tail back no tell-tale nah you know
I'll just do this oh right in the gullet
oh I forgot I had blood god I gotta get
used to that it thrusts me upwards whoo
nope
no I know ah [ __ ] oh god no I'm doing it
all wrong
forgetting all the things I need to do
Wow
I marry you there we go know what I got
to remember 2-2 that is another thing I
need to do hmm
tail tail tail man I really got a I got
to learn how to do that okay you there
we go marry you come here you oh there
you go all right
there we go you punk
okay oh there you are okay you what no
this sorry meant to do meant to set you
on fire no thank you no thank you no
thank you what oh this guy he's such a
dick he's such a douche
you really he really wants some of me
all right where are we where are we oh
oh yes that really gives you the
business are you is that oh I thought
your thing was still on your head
hey you're gonna get a face full of
full-auto that's what you're gonna get
where are you are you bud listen all
right I'm gonna do this and then I'm
gonna do this all right
five what do you got buddy yeah nothing
being stupid I know but I'm having fun
oh don't lose it right at the end here
there we go there we go there we go
that's how you do I just discovered that
I'm really not that fast is the thing
okay oh yeah you are you incus set your
fire kill you there give me a Moreau no
I didn't need to do that you're pathetic
why did way set on you okay where's that
big monk above weird the monkey bug oh
oh yeah you're gonna face full of ass
and that's oh there's the monkey ball
all right desi desi desi desi oh wow
where'd you come from where'd you come
from
stop it
yeesh Asst yes you see sheís all right
stop being silly Billy oh I'm still in
full auto well good I wanted to do that
anyway really silly gameplay here
I gotta admit very silly stuff okay get
you there we go
15 towards that goal oh that was that
was a little crazy for me that was a
little silly a lot of silliness was
happening there but that was fun because
I'm starting to get the groove of like
movement playing around with things
realizing that a lot of these demons are
faster than me so I got to use these
tools to my advantage to get distance so
that I can just start scrunching on
their faces and that's most important to
me I'm guessing this big yellow bar at
the top right he's the boss battle and
I'm really hoping that I'm getting a
boss battle because I am excited about
that hello doom hunter base the UA C's
polar cult this facility is built around
the ruins of an ancient argenta
settlement constructed over 60 million
years ago during Argent dinners
extraterrestrial expansion frozen
carcasses of the agra don hunters have
been located in the glacial wastes
surrounding the complex though their DNA
structure reveals them to be indigenous
to earth there is no fossilized records
of these creatures beyond the frozen
territories of the Argenta settlement
carbon dating of the remarkably
well-preserved beasts suggests they are
nearly 80 million years old predating
all other known forms of complex
earth-based life continuing the cyber
demonic experimentation that began on
mars the cult to study the AGGA Dawn's
potential for resurrection and cyber
augmentation a similar program occurred
at this location millennia ago when dag
priests often cited as hel priests bred
the creatures and genetically modified
them to function as doom hunters if
you're some mutants designed to battle
the doom Slayer and his Knights
sentinels during the unholy Crusades on
Arjun DeNooyer Sentinel records
corroborate this through their military
tanks with many reports of these
creatures among the ranks of the demonic
forces assaulting the armies of the
north during the Argenta Civil War once
the UAC cultist movement publicly
announced its intentions for Earth the
cyber demonic program was revealed to be
the focused on updating the doom
his schematics upgrading their combat
prowess a new assembly center was
constructed near the cultists facility
and a powerful graph tram allowed UAC
workers to safely transport the
biological and mechanical components
needed for the process the resurrection
of the Agra dan hunter requires
cutting-edge technology to be used in
conjunction with occult rituals
conducted by the UAC s necro surgeons
now in the holy fusion of science and
sorcery great stuff good but literally
messing with things beyond your
understanding that's what you want to
see and what is this giant beam what
what is this what does this giant energy
dick shooting up out of the ground what
is that supposed to be at whatever all
the music
oh sorry just had a moment there what
happened oh wow thanks for the
compliment I guess you know that was
just like really nice of you to
acknowledge how huge my dick is and it
meant it is massive thank you
oh okay I get you yes I see okay let's
see what this boob hunters all about all
right what if I missed I've probably
missed a ton of stuff whoa okay wait no
this place is huge okay I barely tapped
into any of this oh there's the boss
damn this place is big
damn oh I missed that I forgot there was
something down there
ah is it worth going back to get can I
even go back and get it I can't okay let
me go back and get that that was not too
far ago I remember seeing that and then
I got distracted by my own awesomeness
yeah there's something here so there's
got to be oh I see it's a down okay so
something in here must lead down all
right where are we Oh got it
easy enough yeah I don't want to miss
out on those because I think those are
gonna unlock a lot of things on the ship
all right let's do this
who else is here huh a big dip big big
big doom guy or girl or pretend that was
cool what I said nice coffin you gonna
bury yourself in that all right what am
I supposed to do here haha thanks for
the ride but Kirino oh ah man I thought
you were being nice I thought you were
being nice to me you know what I don't
need you I think I can make it just to
this one without your help
yeah ooh hey-yeah so you know you suck
you know I know I know a big point that
they were talking about when making this
game is just making the in-between
levels between the wrong thing I'll just
do this no I won't is all miss was
making the in-between travel between
battle set pieces more interesting and
they did I'd say they succeeded in that
because the levels are quite a bit more
intriguing and just like from an eye
candy perspective looking at in all this
and just seeing all this one of my
favorite things about the original doom
that I don't think a lot of people
talked about it when I was a kid when I
looked out at the Vista and if you
compare doom to now it looks like
garbage but when I looked out at the
levels beyond where I could travel I
would look at those mountain ranges and
I'd be like this is so cool look how
huge this area is it really feels like a
world and even back then it looks like
you know crap but compared to compared
to now but to be perfectly honest oh hey
bud oh hey bud hey no that's not right
boring I need to farm up some of this oh
yeah I can afford it
oh why do i it's so instinctive
reloading is so engrained in my brain
all the time what are you you look like
something important and there's a secret
up there well damn the old dusty dry oh
there's some there yeah but just seeing
those vistas and seeing them here again
it's just so fascinating there's so much
detail in the world like around us and I
love that I really do I really truly
honestly appreciate that it's one it's
it's something that may not seem like
something that would affect gameplay but
it is something that affects a game
experience it makes the world feel more
grounded and it it enhances your
appreciation for the kind of world that
you're in
and I think that's equally is important
[Music]
all right where am I hey bats how you
doing
what is this what it would what the hell
can I blow that up oh yes I can
all right so what's your what's your
objective ah oh man you guys are you
guys are gonna get a face full of rocket
what are you doing sonic shooting your
rings
I'm just farming up for the mastery my
dudes does it count for two if I kill -
and what what the hell just happened
there was two I might here there we go
and a headshot Wow pew let's let's count
that as a headshot hey everybody
everyone agreed that was a headshot I
want this mastery real bad I don't know
why I keep thinking I can reload okay
there's gotta be secrets up here oh
there's death look oh wait this secret
ah this place looks literally metal yeah
just like you even being here looking
around it's what I said about
environmental story tone looking at not
around and just appreciating the level
design and all the different details in
here and everything that's baked into it
it's it's just really cool you know what
I mean so cool I love you I really love
you oh god damn you to hell
onward mighty steed I gotta go I'm
appreciating the level design so much
I'm not playing you know what do we got
here
dig ranek dark Viceroy to the chaos
throne and supreme [ __ ] of hell ranek
has long served as one of health
emissaries on earth how long are we
talking here laying the foundation for
the planets inevitable invasion how
inevitable are we talking here secrecy
erratic has prepared the hell gate
awaiting the omen of the sixth seal that
which signals the age of Wrath
sure which will cleanse earth as
foretold by the maker prophets
ranek worked closely with Olivia Pierce
during the development of the original
Mars project and since her death is
taken total control of the UAC his
promises of wealth power and everlasting
life have corrupted the organization
from within absolving its employees of
their moral conscience accelerating the
sacrifice of Earth in exchange for the
lure of Archon energy and the promise of
undying union with hel D grunick
previously served the king of origin
Donora as a sentinel priest guiding the
art tent to spiritual growth as a
hallowed figure after the betrayal he
abandoned his homeworld working on
behalf of the Khan maker and personally
overseeing the transformation of
viewable planets
ranek has constructed a veritable
fortress and the polar caps to protect
him during his dark work okay sounds
like this guy needs to die whoa
what is that why can't I go in there all
right fine ooh ooh speed boost after
glory kill that actually I think is
gonna be very useful because that's one
of the things that I noticed I'm kind of
slow on my feet when I don't have a -
ready so I would like to be able to
glory kill and then move faster I also
got to use my blood punch way more what
is that oh that looks fun this old place
looks fun oh all right uh any other
secrets that I missed nah I just got to
go for it and not be squashed right
that's how you get squashed
oh I timed the gap I thought I was gonna
get squashed
what point
nerds we're gonna get squashed
is that two-for-one kill oh you think
you're gonna get me ha okay
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh boy I
missed
hang on Han an ant ant
fish oh my goodness that was a big boy a
big boy touka blew me I could blow me
the big boy
what are you doing what are you doing
bye-bye no no your hands what happened
to your hands
dude you should pay attention things are
happening around you I was doing that
over there
oh nice block and your heads gonna be
blue and your heads gone did I just go
in a big way did not bye bye mana you
know if these guys actually like
coordinated they wouldn't have to worry
about fighting each other so much and
they wouldn't have to worry about me
picking off their weak points from a
distance a very safe distance point oh
my god headshots work up in that guy man
he did not move that guy he was
steadfast he was he had orders to hold
his ground and boy howdy he held them
alright let's go for this oh boy oh boy
it's getting tight here alright uh we're
okay here
okay here
hey stop that stop I'm low on health cuz
I don't know what I hit oh stop well he
died how what all right what am I
looking for there's something in here
hello ah punchable are push a ball
portion punch those are my two actions
all right is this my coffin oh my hello
hey there was a big version of that that
I punched okay bye well glad I did
whatever that was why did I do that mom
oh there's a dude down there how do I
get down how do I get up ooh
all right well interesting so there's
got to be a way to get up because that
tells me to go over there but there's
also got to be a way to get down that's
what that tells me over there okay is it
whoa-ho-ho almost fell down almost went
kaboom Oh
nope definitely not that way I'll lose
all my health just to falling in fits ah
see I see I see I see I see
yes uh-huh okay oh I see interesting but
also what about getting down below hand
before we commit to this let me back up
a bit
ah there's also that there but how do
you open that puzzles puzzles peas auras
posers oh there's a secret in there too
Oh
on the other side oh I know I know what
to do I know what to do
I know what to do I know I said that I
wasn't gonna try to get all the secrets
but for some reason I'm really
incentivized to do it I don't know why
hooha yes yes this is how we do it this
is what we do this is what I do anyway
oh [ __ ] look at me oh my god Commander
Keen oh hell yeah alright what did that
do for me
oh [ __ ] I can go over there now yes yes
yes what did this do what does this do
why am I here probably the logical way
that I was supposed to go for this
secret out there - okay this is
apparently there's a secret up there ooh
what if I know that wouldn't make sense
oh wait this would make sense oh hi Oh
one-shot kill on stager oh hell yeah
oh and hell yeah oh hell yes I'm getting
all those regards of yay for me
Oh a portal huh all right I got those
nice Oh all right let's do this
Oh nailed it hey dude
we weren't even looking at me you don't
even know I'm there all right oh yeah
yeah keep fighting nerds how you almost
killed me just from that whoa oh no you
know stop bad bad kako demon bad cackle
Badcock otaku right ow ow ow ow two can
play at that game
oh come on
oh that killed it I mean the super
shotgun is immensely powerful I just
want to say that in case anyone was
doubting here yes it seems right ooh
what's that for a secret I think yes oh
definitely that secret territory
I don't really need a boost here whoop
maybe this isn't secret maybe this is
just what it's supposed to be here's
something clacking up there okay yeah
we're getting flame belch boost oh hell
yeah oh hell yeah Oh punch it off just
like everything crush it so what am i
doing with those crystals am i shoving
them inside me I don't know why that's
my first instinct but I'm assuming oh oh
sorry yeah yeah you guys should get more
security ow
No something tells me those guys are
pretty pathetic
okay seminal battery Oh fancy
I like dude there's one thing I gotta
say about this place is they have a
sense of style whoa what did I get
oh I was supposed to get all that oh
sweet right finally not really a secret
but hey it was fun okay so you saying
that makes me think I'm more of a
betrayer type than I was
wait no then Who am I Who am I what am i
doing hey bud you're gonna do this for
me okay
hello logo bye hey whoa you suck
hey stop
boom soup right in the head
okay you stop that number 100 gone
didn't even get to glory kill you taking
all the fun out of it alright let's do
some plasma stuff that I haven't done
let's switch over to the first wave mode
and alright so there's something to the
right here the coin I there we go
that's nice I feels good I feels real
nice there's something here up oh I see
you but BAM fist bump bro alright thanks
for the coin the dude
sneak attack sneak double shotgun attack
never saw it coming oh I'm very close to
getting that mastery these pools of
blood nice they are to be perfectly
honest they they are pools of blood all
right oh hey bud try to hit me try to
hit me you can't you can't you won't you
oh whoops
I'm out parently out of ammo so I'm
gonna do this
Wow whoever's nice love it
come on do you think you can mess with
the legs of me hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey stop point your everything here
all of you just your control unit man by
that I mean your brain well that's big
that's cool
that looks neat am i fighting that oh
that was just what was that what was
that just decoration that serve a
function link what does that do
okay whatever you say buddy boo nice
pools of blood all right cool what are
you what do you do but purpose to serve
the music
okay sorry I just needed that love it
love it so much I know they're gearing
me up for a boss fight right now but I
can't help but be anything but
underwhelmed by this pathetic display
they have here
hello I'll or I thought I had the keys
don't I have keys oh oh I see this isn't
actually the fight here the fights are
common pop nice nice
well just throw my head right into that
that that felt good that felt good
got that I really want to shoot that but
apparently it doesn't die where am I
going ah here we go
coin kiss okay man they really should
think about setting those up somewhere
else they're very convenient for me oh
hi you good-bye you so close I did it
again oh wait but I know how to do this
boom two for one
alright we are looking at a coin over
there so let's see about getting
you're not even hitting me my dude not
even hitting me whoa
hey buddy I see you what ow
dad's three of those took away all of my
health so ah no not like this please
I'm very sad now I'm very sad hope you
know that
very sad I'm all the way over here now
that's very sad for me I've been very
sad having coin man hey how you doing
hey good to see you I should spend these
but I won't not right now anyway
I found a secret what do you mean to
found a secret I thought that's where I
was supposed to go you telling me that
was it what I was supposed to do ow oh
yeah I can make that hi hey how you
doing hey hey good see it nice chain
saws double chainsaws actually I like
that that's good why am i doing am I
just building am i it's like a
build-a-bear but a demon it's build a
demon I'm building my perfect demon that
I want to fight because no one else will
give me an actual challenge I see I get
you okay well now I did that feel good
about myself yeah how do I get out this
one never mind that's how I okay lore
once a race of beasts like hunters the
doom hunter creature was known to the
Sentinel warriors in ages past as lethal
stalkers of the metal age extracted from
the frozen depths of the polar tundra
the doom hunter belongs to an ancient
race uncovered during cultist excavation
of the remote Arctic so you're telling
me this thing this right here is from
Earth before even humans get here that
that's that's nuts all right sure I
believe you do monitor ceremoniously
systematically resurrected and rebuilt
great high degree of mental faculty a
sentient brutal hunting instinct
augmented with the armaments of a tank
division great that sounds good
I'm glad for that there's some kind of a
secret here not sure how to get there
but I can tell there's a secret my my
nose really can hunt out any secret
anywhere I just have to figure out how
got it oh oh god it's so cute oh that's
very cute
all right I'm low on health you got some
more of those there we go that's what
I'm talking about
I do i I think you're expecting this to
be not just a trivial encounter where I
just absolutely destroy everything that
you know and love and
I thought you would appreciate the
century a true
aha news a great bargain on hunters from
the camels rare right long thought to be
extinct created an army a slayer is not
sitting US during the unholy crusade
some improvements on the design of it
may enjoy what is undoubtedly my finest
work okay cool
all right you're gonna die ooh weak
point oh that makes it easy
oh yeah you know actually that's not a
bad idea okay how about I do that hang
on let me get some distance I got to
change out - oh hi didn't notice you
there can I have some thank you all
right I'm gonna change out to this we're
going full auto ba-bop ba-bop doing
exactly what I was foretold I'm a whole
ship ammo oh yeah oh yeah okay
all right here we go cluster what that's
not what I meant to do this this is what
I meant to do yeah The Heretic I don't
think you know what heretics all about
if you think I'm there to hear is to be
perfectly honest I think you might
actually be you the heretic hey bud hey
how you doing you look at in that double
jump there you're unlucky I'm here now
can you hold on a second and then oh he
doesn't freeze interesting whoa okay
let's dance baby let's dance
whoo oh I'm so close to getting meathook
Master well shouldn't get close to that
guy that's for sure whoo all right let
me wash it missed a [ __ ] okay hang on
let's Oh goddamn it not what I meant to
do there we go
that's more like it Oh caught you midair
baby all right how about we do one of
these discs uh-huh
nice ah okay alright now I got to take
it seriously because I'm low on health
you look like a capable volunteer yeah
ha
now I'm entered nonetheless okay thank
you for your contribution to the
fighting efforts yeah yeah yeah let's
see is this gonna affect you now well
not if I miss oh oh oh oh all wait don't
go don't go guys so sad they didn't want
to play no mo oh oh wait maybe there's
gonna be like a stage to down below I
don't think it's over oh yeah oh yeah oh
this feels like stage two what are we
doing they're not done yet huh
oh now I gotta fight two of them okay
all right point okay can you not get in
the way of my big Rockets then you not
lock on to that target
smash the heretic okay alright sure
whatever you say I will I will Bubba
[Music]
oh god I just killed myself I I actually
almost devastated myself there that was
all me although God do not do that to me
sorry bud you you get to die you get to
die very very very horribly oh yeah hey
none of that we will have none of that
in this house I will have none of that
in this house thank you thank you
what are you doing buddy get out of here
a blood punch baby
oh yes yes yes yes yes oh my goodness
yes oh man oh mama did I get the mastery
I might've oh I did I got the mastery oh
yes yeah I got the mastery oh I'm so
happy
Oh what that I thought that was a pit of
doom all right you are right you are
right all right let's let's settle down
here let's settle down let's settle down
oh yeah
now I'm getting into the rhythm of it oh
yes all right oh my goodness
okay I'm getting hurt bad you know how
about we don't hi bud
oh whoa what the Frick what do you just
hit me with okay I got to be careful I'm
getting close to epic destruction here
oh I love that that's good yes please
yes please
[Music]
oh yeah now I'm feeling it oh what's
that oh what's that this perfect
perfect no talk no nothing straight to
the point and the point is that you're
gonna die and that was feeling really
good towards that that last battle
towards the end of it I was feeling the
flow the meathook the fire the fodder
the ammo the armor I was getting there
what punch shockwave is now more
powerful that's something that I don't
use I don't use enough blood punch I
know that for a fact
hey I did pretty good what challenge
didn't I do Oh
fire in the hole I didn't even realize I
needed to do that oops
hmm all right let's move on am I going
back to base because I got a lot of
things that I need to upgrade at the
base the fortress of doom Oh game
[Music]
[Music]
the super gore nest are you telling me a
super gore nest because I rip out the
heart of those gorgeous I remember the
name of the gore nest back oh I remember
that which means that I get to rip out
our super big heart from a super big
Gore nest also what did you say I need
to grab what am i grabbing yes yes yes
in every way yes yes yes yes yes and yes
and then I want that the unmake er do
i'ma get you Oh imma get you okay so I
need to decide what I would like to
spend my central batteries on wasn't
there something the doubt fit oh how
many central better giant hmm
I've six Oh what else do we have what up
what else we got
ooh that I like those those are good
okay definitely a contender okay so
those are good if I spend on anything it
might be those uh what do we got on your
sludge nothing can't go down there so we
got sludge and - and there's something
up top oh yeah oh oh my the classic
outfit oh oh me oh my I think I must
ooh I feel as though I must mmm I do
like the current suit I don't know if I
like it as much as the suit from 2016
but there's no way that I can't not do
the classic suit
I'm not even one for customization I'll
tell you guys straight up I'm not
usually one for that but but but but but
but but look at that but look at that
but what what what what what what what
but how do I change it I think I gotta
go back to the main menu I think and I'm
just gonna go well that's not me that
ain't me that ain't me at all are
hanging Flair there we go oh that's what
I'm talkin about
well that's what I've always been talkin
yeah cuz the current suits pretty cool
look classic Oh classy classy oh that's
classy oh that's classy ho that's
climbing wow that's classic I'm having
so much fun I really not joking I'm
having so much stuff fun the story is
losing me a little bit the story is like
going off on a like oh hell heaven God's
sure whatever to point me in the
direction and tell me to kill something
I will kill it and that is frickin fun
hopefully I'm wearing the thing but
there's two other items that I'm going
to get I think I think
mm-hmm I think these are definitely
worth the money
that being said wasn't there wasn't
there some other like outside area that
I need to do them before I do that
before I'm stupid let me go see
something this what is this I forget
what it said it was oh this is just
another outfit I'll screw that noise who
needs that I've got the only outfit I'm
ever gonna want
oh that's club that's boom 2016 suit ooh
it's awfully shadowed in there but yeah
that's 2016 oh I do like that one but
I'm good
I've got classic I'm gonna go for
functional over prosthetic sovereign
also take note that on this suit that
I'm wearing it said the tagline was it
still fits so I think they're really
trying to connect to this character that
I am too that doom character but I don't
know how those timelines line up is the
thing I really don't know let's do the
armor one because I want the armor in
ammo combo armor health um is fine all
right let's see how that do I do have a
tendency to run out of armor more but if
I'm using my meat hook properly than I
should shouldn't have too much trouble
with it and then nice okay cool
give me that thank you all right I'm
gonna need to spend some of my points on
some of my suit upgrades and my gun
upgrades but for now Oh wrong way but
for now I'm doing pretty good
I'm gonna go find a super Gore nest and
I'm gonna punch the tits off of it
because that's how I do where is it let
me do my suit stuff first oh yeah faster
weapons which that's it that's a must I
need that let's do this
personal yeah definitely
okay cool all right we're good there
let's go I need to go find a Gorn esque
to explode we oh no I got a feeling I'm
gonna deal with a lot of buttholes oh
well at least I'm going back to earth oh
[Music]
they just blew and that was the respawn
hi bye
all right cool good mmm
don't be silly hi bye hey bye hey uh
there you go
you'd think that a grenade would blow up
a wall but apparently not what's going
on here Uncas dinkus then did I catch
you in the tuchus get you in the nog if
you in the nog damn Oh
oh my god what the hell literally how
what oh that's so cool and gross but
cool damn that's bonkers
ah caca dubbins no beer yeah bruh you
you bricks
ah they're not real you're not real I
tried to reload again but you're not
real what's going on guys who's fighting
or teef how about I am
Oh your head is gone dude your head is
so gone oh my god oh my god I love it
how about hey how you doing had gone
damn these these monk of us is they they
doing too good on the whole killing me
Department wah-wah but oh who's doing
who is making the floor electrical who's
doing that don't wear missiles oh hey
bud that blast wave does knock off knock
off their uh
their rockets and stuff which is very
nice oh my god just just having the
mobility of this device is so nice oh
hey welcome to the party pinky I wasn't
exactly where you are right now but
oh you're too tough from the front I
can't I can't hit you but I can do this
oh whoops
no I can't
nice okay there's a couple secrets here
that I definitely need to get there seem
to be a couple secrets floating around
hither and thither there's this one hey
cutie Mecca zombie very cute very cute
and I can definitely get in there here
oh no oh you dick do not block me I want
to go in there let me in there
let me in there I'm a baby let me in now
that's a meaty penis all right fine
I'll move on why did suddenly I want to
know how to get all the secrets what did
I get I got it some kind of a codex hell
growth the growth exhibits certain
predetermined qualities in the
consumption of our ecosystem it creates
environmental conditions more conducive
for its own continued formation in
effect employing an organic method of
terra formation the resulting
environment is hostile to terrestrial
life producing atmospheric toxins and a
multitude of environmental hazards
although it is understood that the
growth accelerates the arrival of demon
life on earth it is not clear how the
growth stem self is originated or
whether there was some sort of catalysts
that created the conditions necessary
for their existence it is believed that
if the source of the grouse can be
identified there may be a means of
uprooting the entire formation you're
being like a super Gore nest you got it
buddy come on the job you called doom
guy you get doom guy and doom guy knows
how to deal with you rapscallions
a comfortable one you say uh how about
no all right what do we got for this
charge up particular that embeds and
demons and explodes destroy our blade oh
I mean the árboles is pretty cool I
gotta go with uh if I have this it's
like to take out big things from a
distance
I've got like the sniper for the machine
gun which I might at some point change
out to micro missiles but oh yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah hey bud you want to die
all right
went right through him what a Wimpy baby
hey guys hey you mind if I cut in
yeah I'm funny
point what miss me sorry wow that sucks
for you I am having a blast
oh you you still a threat to some people
Wow who's hitting me who just hit me oh
you oh you
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah there we go well kicked
all their asses show them who's what now
what who there's a secret up there a
weird yeah god it's so goopy yeah but
there is a secret up here oh so I knew I
was gonna go it's gonna be oh but you
you suck oh I knew it was gonna be all
butthole all day long it's gonna be the
level of butthole but that's okay I've
dealt with it before I'm fine
why is it gotta be undulating that's
what I don't get it's it's just all
undulating off Totem increase the speed
and damage of nearby demons buff demons
will endlessly spawn until the buff
totem is destroyed well I guess I gotta
kill the buff totem then back you are
faster oh my god you're so much faster
what the hell whoa whoa that was no joke
what the hell that was no joke what you
didn't tell me it was gonna be like that
all right fine
where's the buff totem I'll kill it
Jesus Christmas where is this buff totem
jiminy crisp oh my god this home honey
what the hell you guys suck stop being
asses oh my goodness gracious gravy
where's the buff totem and I'm not
seeing no buff totem oh how did I not
hit that holy crap oh it's in there
jiminy Christmas oh man that that's all
whoa whoa Wow Oh oh my hello friend ah I
should have known buttholes
no it's butthole heaven I can't die die
oh my god let me get the coin
please don't kill me
honk honk honk oh my god did I rip its
heart open give me a card thank you I
just need thank you hmm all right cool
thank you aah who's there stop being
there yes okay uh yeah yeah yeah uh-huh
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh you know what I
take some of this and one of these and
where does this go ah this was a mistake
out no out no out we're even oh my god
you I think I got you on your teleport
Punk
skewed how did that not Oh God here it
is kill it
destroy it there we go okay got it
now you suck and you J Sims Christmas
that is one way to do it yeah that's one
way to make it a lot more difficult guys
you found it out there it's so much
faster when that's like that oh so
scared
good god oh my god what are these oh my
god
oh I love it I love it but I hate it I
love it's so pulsating draw buttholes
all day long guys I sure called it on
this one is all butthole all day oh how
do I get to you oh I have no idea how to
get to half of you I don't even know
what anything is anymore
I miss industrial looking places
all right good that armor would have
helped a while ago or really helped
oh now you're open all right yeah I'm
completely out of ammo on pretty much
everything let's definitely do this all
right what do ya
what are ya what do you what are you yes
please gimme you I need you thank you
very much thank you very much I need you
whoa not the big guy oh my god not the
big guy that's not what I wanted all
right take two
all right you freeze you go there you go
there you give me you and then you go
there you go there I'm gonna blow up
your armaments donkus are good good good
oh no time I forgot time
ah I was very close though least I got
some ammo for it
em'ly man glory kills take up too much
time for those I think the trick is Oh
God out done I think the trick is not to
do glory kills in those because it is
just too much time alright alright what
did I do
there's something else in there too
there's a power e power up but how do
you get to that yeah it's behind there
but how would you oh there's some kind
of down there okay interesting so
somewhere industrial leads to right
there I'm willing to bet it'd be back
there it's probably when I go through
the teleporter there'll be a way to go
up around cuz I don't think in this big
ol hall of meat here that there's a way
yeah cuz I can't even go back okay cool
let's go through the teleporter let's
see what happens I got the yellow Gork
heat and I'm not happy about it and I
well I'm gonna remember what pocket
that's in and I'm never gonna put
anything in there ever again
okay okay bouquet nice okay do I need
anything else I mean the faster glory
kills might actually be nice because
they do take a while you know actually
I'm gonna replace the the UM blood Bunch
room because to be perfectly honest I
don't use blood punch enough and there
usually aren't enemies to get caught in
the shockwave anyway it only is
marginally beneficial oh my goodness
when you said super gore nest I didn't
assume you meant that super can I get
some ammo
seem to be missing some ammo here you
can I thank you
they also punch what blood punch oh my
god there we go yeah faster get the
speed up there we go that's how you do
Oh what are you doing whoa hey bud Oh
God Oh God okay house
dumb of me oh come on what the heck what
the heck
give me something to shoot oh yeah cut
you meet everybody punched you oh yeah
now we're getting it
give me something to shoot hey how you
doing friend Oh from downtown from
downtown oh do not block him from my
glory oh look at you oh is that a quad
damage that is Wow whoa whoa God they
hurt so bad no do not block me from my
glory you guys suck and you're going
you're gonna get sucked are you oh there
you are
run I'm runnin oh no I got quad damage
right at the end there definitely it's
most useful point I'm very proud of that
and I'm proud of myself as all of you
should be the secret down there in the
whole hidey hole decide you knew this
hidey hole oh but it's closed but
there's something on the other side
there we go there we go infinite ammo
whoo yes please god I'm the worst about
getting power-ups aren't I okay what are
we facing next ooh there's something
above me wow I didn't notice that that
is pretty crazy not gonna lie that's
pretty nuts that's pretty ridiculous I
got locked on target
okay so there's got to be a moment when
that thing comes close enough to be able
to jump on it oh no nevermind it doesn't
go nearly high enough what I wanted
oh no it's something else okay that
drops down okay so it's definitely not
here at least not here right now so that
just leaves this big Mamba Jamba right
here whatever this is it looks cool it
looks really cool like that's pretty
sick but unfortunately I'm all out of
time for this episode thank you
everybody so much for watching I hope
you're enjoying this I know I am I'm
getting good and I'm getting kills so
thanks again stay tuned for the next
episode in just a couple days here
subscribe if you want to see and ring
the bell if you want to know when it
goes up and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]